hey guys merry and Dan here at TGS 2016
and we just got done playing the first
DLC for dark souls 3 this is ashes of
arendelle it's a pretty unique look to
it what you think damn I loved it it's a
kind of a snowy area I believe I think
it's a painted world and when we were
bombing around it was like very stormy
very blizzardy it was very hard to get a
sense of where your enemies were in
relation to where you were I mean I ran
up a hill at one point got to the top
and it was like five dudes who just
suddenly attacked me yeah same thing
with me it's kind of reminded me of the
dlc for dark souls 2 crown of the ivory
King because there's so much snow
falling that often you could have maybe
a projectile thrown at ya jee and you
won't see it until it's hit you right in
the face I definitely got hit with a few
people like throwing daggers at me but
the world itself is also quite a trip we
we went through a part where the ground
completely Falls exactly it feels like
there's so many surprises hidden within
this this new area that like we couldn't
really crack as many as i would have
liked but I we saw so many things that
was just like oh this is so new and so
exciting but I'm really excited to sit
down and actually get into it really
figure out what's going on in that area
yeah let's talk about some of the the
new enemy types that are coming at you I
saw some pretty intense stuff first of
all a skeleton bug type yeah creature
the kind of huge but yeah crawling up to
you on there pretty sneaky a little oh
there's a lot of really mobile enemies
this new area I think the main thing you
guys are gonna notice from this is
wolves oh man those wolves and they seem
to roam in packs as well which makes
them even more terrifying so if you
attack one all of a sudden you've got to
deal with three or four and there while
they're weak they're incredibly fast and
i found that was really hard for me to
take them down because i'd be focusing
on one and just get flanked by two more
yeah they're nipping at your ankles the
whole time and they're fast little
buggers you can't use any heavy attacks
on them so they could actually be quite
difficult to manipulate you're gonna
want to end up using 360 moves you know
there's a few especially with like
having a dual weapons would be really
nice to be able to have like a nice 360
tack might be valuable for that i also
found not walking on was the way I was
able to deal with those groups of
enemies because i always make that
mistake of like walking onto one dude
and then I'm just stuck and if you don't
like wolves then you're not going to
like the main box of that area I mean
even if you like wolves you're probably
not gonna like that boss cuz he was a
nightmare that's right so like not
there's actually it's just a dude
hanging out in a giant pack of wolves
but once you get him down to about half
yeah he calls in his giant pet wolf
which is just super fast super strong I
managed to take down the dude but that
wolf was impossible he's got this dash
it seems to cover the entire area in one
go he is huge and he because he is so
wide it is very difficult to dodge
absolutely you can't end up getting in
between his legs or anything like that I
was it was a tough guy to take down so
you got these two enemies going after
you and then the guy who called himself
is quite quick he seemed to have like a
really fast slash attack but he could
also throw I think was a nice spell and
so I kept getting hit by that and it was
pushing up my frozen meter and then I'd
start slowing down and it was just it
was killing me it was it was so
difficult which is great which is
fantastic so I think that's a pretty
good first look of ashes of arendelle
and I'm looking forward to seeing what
other surprises because Justin this very
short 10 minute demo we were able to
play they had like five or six tricks up
their sleeves exactly play with the
player a little bit so looking forward
to that and for everything else that is
tokyo game show related you guys are
gonna want to see tunes to gamespot